use the discriminant to state the number
and type of solutions for the equation
negative 3x squared plus 5x minus 4 is
equal to 0 and so just as a reminder
you're probably wondering what is the
discriminant and we can just review it
by looking at the quadratic formula so
if I haven't found a quadratic equation
in standard form ax squared plus BX plus
C is equal to 0 we know that the
quadratic formula which is really just
derived from completing the square right
over here tells us that the roots of
this or the solutions of this quadratic
equation are going to be x is equal to
negative b plus or minus the square root
of b squared minus 4ac all of that over
2a
now you might know from experience
applying this a little bit that a lot
we're going to get different types of
solutions depending on what happens
under the radical sign over here as you
can imagine if what's under the radical
sign over here is positive then we're
going to get an actual real number as
its principal square root and when we
take the positive and negative version
of it we're going to get two real
solutions so if b squared minus 4ac
which and this is what the discriminant
really is it's just this is it's just
this expression under the radical sign
of the quadratic formula if this is
greater than zero then we're going to
have two real roots then we're going to
have I'm gonna have two real two real
roots or two real solutions to this
equation right here if b squared minus
4ac if b squared minus 4ac is equal to
zero then this whole thing is just going
to be equal to zero is going to be the
plus or minus square root of 0 which is
just 0 so it's plus or minus zero well
when you add or subtract 0 that doesn't
change the solution so the only solution
is going to be negative B over 2a so
you're only going to have one real
solution so this is going to be one I'll
just write the number one one real
solution or you could kind of say you
have a repeated root here you have you
can kind of say you're having it twice
or you could say one real one real
solution or one
now if B squared minus 4ac were negative
you might already imagine what will
happen if this expression right over
here is negative we're taking the square
root of a negative number so where you
would get then get an imaginary number
right over here and so we would add or
subtract the same imaginary number so
we'll have two complex solutions and not
only what we have two complex solutions
but they will be the conjugates of each
of each other so if you have one complex
solution for a quadratic equation the
other solution will also be a complex
solution and will be its complex
conjugate so here we would have two we
would have two complex complex solutions
so numbers that have a real part and an
imaginary part and not only are they
just complex but they're the conjugates
of each other the imaginary parts have
different signs so let's look at B
squared minus 4ac over here this is our
a this is our B and this is our C let me
label them a b c and i can do that
because we've written it in standard
form everything is on one side or in
particular the left hand side we have a
zero on the right hand side we've
written it in descending I guess power
form or the descending degree or we have
our second degree term first and our
first degree term then our constant term
and so we can evaluate the discriminant
v squared is 5 B is 5 so b squared is 5
squared minus 4 times a which is
negative 3 times C which is negative 4 I
have to be careful C is this whole thing
C is negative 4 and so and I don't know
if I said 4 earlier but C is negative 4
we have to make sure we take the sign
into consideration so times C which is
negative 4 over here and so this is 25
and then negative 3 times negative 4
that is positive 12 and then 4 times 12
is 48 but we have a negative out here so
25 minus 48 and 25 minus 48 we don't
even have to look we didn't have to do
the math we can do we can just say that
this is definitely going to be less than
zero you can actually figure it out this
is equal to this is equal to negative
this is equal to negative 13 if I did oh
no sorry negative 23 negative 23 which
is clearly less than
so our discriminant in this situation is
less than zero so we are going to have
two complex roots here and they're going
to be each other's conjugates